here with much more Fox Business host
Charles paint is with us let me
understand this so they got in
California a 13 and a half percent state
income tax on top of the top federal
income tax rate of 40 percent so that's
53 uh and a half cents out of every
dollar just an income tax never mind
property taxes gas taxes other taxes
that we all pay uh so now if you've
managed to save money and by definition
quote become wealthy now they want
another bite at the Apple and then when
you die they get another bite at the
Apple uh how many times they're going to
take a bite of the Apple
well they're working on one more really
feverishly now Sean because you
mentioned uh the massive Exodus of
people there uh at the exit tax now this
came up a couple of years ago they've
been trying to work it in where if you
leave the state they can still tax you
and so it's like the song Hotel
can never leave right
it was a couple years ago a few
proposals they started low right 30
million then down to the single digit
Millions this one is an extra wealth tax
so they'll start with the billionaires
first and they'll take a big chunk out
of all of their assets they'll add them
all up and then in a couple years it
goes down to 50 million you and I have
seen this movie before uh at some point
it would go from 50 million to 20
million to 10 million to 1 million to
four hundred thousand dollars you cannot
leave the state so you can't afford your
electric vehicle so you can't afford a
mortgage so you can't afford all the
taxes you just laid out too bad you
shouldn't have been here now here's
here's the rub uh what did they say
justifies this well California wants to
recoup some of the money that it's
invested in businesses and individuals
you know that old Canard we heard a lot
from President Obama we heard a lot from
Elizabeth Warren that if you walk on the
sidewalk somehow the state it's partly
responsible for your success forget
about the taxes we pay every day forget
about the blood sweating shares forget
about the savings and the sacrifice the
fact that you live in California means
that you owe California and how dare you
attempt to leave let me ask you you know
in in the early years of my adult life
the many years and there were a lot of
them while I was living paycheck to
paycheck I never looked at anybody else
and thought they should be paying for
anything that I own or have in life in
any way
have we grown a portion of this society
that feels that entitled that they want
to empower and embolden their government
to take from this group of people and
redistribute it to that group of people
in other words have enough Americans now
bought into this redistribution
capitalism socialism model is that is
that now a a prevalent point of view
have I missed the boat on this
I I don't think we're there yet but I
got to tell you President Biden gave it
his best shot last year earned income
tax credits for couples making 300 000
you know they took the the Groundswell
and they took it up a few notches
government handing you money paying you
more money not to work than you would
have made working and of course with
Society with children with kids in
school they're trying to drive home this
message there's something I would say
and Nate there's something about the
ethos of this nation raising yourself up
by the bootstraps that's still in our
core uh they haven't been able to unwind
it but I tell you what they have done a
really good job they've chipped away at
it this entitlement notion and this
fairness notion it goes hand in hand and
that somehow if someone's got a lot more
money than you do something nefarious is
afoot and the government will make it
right they'll take a big chunk from them
uh keep most for themselves and give you
a few crumbs like you when I was growing
up if I saw someone I remember the first
time I saw someone with initials on
their shirt on their sleeves or their
shirt I say I can't wait to make money
I'll do that all my shirts have that
right it's just something I wanted to do
it's just one of these drivers when my
daughter was born my first child don't
you know how hard I worked that's all
the motivation I needed not envy I do
want to share one thing though because
the clock is ticking if you live in
California real quick Sean you need to
do these things right now you need to
get out of this state turn over your
driver's license register your cars in a
different state uh terminate all your
Club memberships while you're there
relocate your family to a new State uh
get all your heirlooms everything even
photographs take them out of the state
right now notify your friends that
you're moving get your holiday birthday
card send them from your new address
outside of California change your
professional affiliations and finally
limit any physical contact in California
if you are making money you think you're
going to make more money if you're
bursting your butt to try to make the
American dream move now if you can you
know a couple of things I in the years
when I needed jobs and I never got hired
by a poor person in my life I got hired
by people that could afford to pay me
um two characteristics every wealthy
person I've ever met in my life they
have two qualities that are consistent
one is they're smart and two they're
hard working I would imagine the smart
part of them is going to start exiting
California if they try to implement this
quickly agree or disagree
I agree but real quick they're also very
frugal they're also very frugal right
now in this country the most frugal
group of Americans are the wealthiest
Americans out there they're trading down
when they go shopping they're not buying
stuff they can't afford they're smart
they say they believe in the long term
all right Charles Payne thank you my
friend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else